una lectura sobre esto es que el gran
protagonista de la reapertura de la
frontera es el comercio al final de
cuentas es sobre lo cual los dos países
se sienten más afectados en términos de
las comunidades que están digamos a un
lado y otro lado de la frontera
obviamente y esto parece muy interesante
y es que las de hecho la el quiebre de
las relaciones entre Venezuela y
Colombia comenzaron por el quiebre de
las relaciones comerciales y de hecho de
eso después derivó la ruptura total de
relaciones diplomáticas y políticas lo
que vimos con el gobierno Gustavo Petro
es que primero hizo el establecimiento
de relaciones diplomáticas y políticas y
después con este hito del día de hoy
pues vemos que hay un restablecimiento
del comercio por lo tanto vemos que hay
una especie de restablecimiento de la
confianza para asentar al final de
cuentas los resultados en términos
económicos obviamente y coincido mucho
con algunos analistas la no presencia
del presidente Nicolás Maduro pues tiene
relación con la cuestión mencionar a lo
del informe de la misión independiente
de Naciones Unidas y obviamente el
protagonismo se lo llevó hoy también el
presidente Gustavo Petro porque es una
promesa de campaña que había hecho
durante la digamos las elecciones
presidenciales Manuel hablabas de la
confianza existe de confianza plena
digamos por parte de los empresarios
colombianos con la inestabilidad que
siempre ha manejado digamos
políticamente el gobierno venezolano
Esos son los pasos que ha dado el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro al acercar
tanto a la segreminaciones con las
autoridades venezolanas de hecho el
principal
enviado o quien ha hecho de las veces de
intermediario en esa serie de
negociaciones ha sido el ministro de
comercio e incluso el ministro de
transporte entonces obviamente lo que se
busca es tratar de restaurar esa
confianza que se perdió en términos
políticos Pero obviamente con una
afectación muy importante en términos de
los negocios y obviamente lo que hace a
buscar es que estos resultados
económicos se están asentados sobre la
idea de una estabilidad jurídica por eso
lo que se busca con esa Ronda de
negociaciones que han dado digamos lugar
al final de cuentas con este
restablecimiento desde las relaciones
comerciales es Buscar que los
empresarios se sientan en confianza para
invertir en un nuevo mercado un viejo
nuevo mercado alrededor decirlo al final
de cuentas debido a que ese rompimiento
de relaciones afectó por una serie valor
de millones de dólares Obviamente el
comercio negocios colombianos en
Venezuela obviamente habrá también que
ver un poco la idea de cuánto puede
recibir Venezuela de las exportaciones
de nosotros los colombianos Y eso Será
algo que tendrá que arreglar este el
gobierno en Caracas